bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
france 24 mi nombre es álvaro cordero
este primero de julio se cumplieron 25
años del regreso de hong kong a la
soberanía china tras 150 años de
administración británica bajo la promesa
de un país dos sistemas la mayoría de
los componentes acogieron con alegría su
vuelta china pero un cuarto de siglo
después la situación es bien diferente
los ciudadanos han visto como el control
de beijing se ha multiplicado y como las
libertades se han reducido la historia
de hong kong comenzó a ser diferente a
la de china en 1842 luego de que este
país se diera a reino unido esta ciudad
tras la guerra del opio
hong kong se desarrolló como un
importante centro capitalista a nivel
global en contraste con el resto del
país que desde 1949 fue regido por un
sistema comunista una cuestión que
resultó humillante para china y que hizo
que presionará durante décadas para su
devolución hasta que lo consiguió en
1984 ese año reino unido y china
liderados en ese entonces por margaret y
den xiaoping firmaron una declaración
conjunta en la que los británicos
devolvería en hong kong con una serie de
condiciones la más importante de ellas
era que china se comprometiera a
respetar el sistema capitalista y la
democracia hongkonesa durante los
primeros 50 años tras la adhesión un
término que sería acuñado por xiaoping
como un país dos sistemas los
preparativos de esta devolución duraron
más de doce años hasta que el 1 de julio
de 1997 se realizó la entrega oficial
entre numerosas celebraciones la
cordialidad fue máxima entre los dos
países y la alegría se extendió entre la
mayoría de la población ante lo que
parecía un ilusionante futuro en el que
hong kong podría disfrutar de las
libertades de una democracia pero
formando parte otra vez de china
y estoy muy emocionada y muy conmovida
al esperar que llegue este momento es
algo muy emocionante
a los hongkoneses disfrutaron de
beneficios que no existían en la china
continental como la libertad de prensa
de opinión o el derecho al voto valores
democráticos que muchos pensaron que
podrían inspirar a beijing para promover
una cierta apertura política pero eso
nunca fue así más bien todo lo contrario
aunque durante los primeros años se
respetaron los puntos básicos del
acuerdo las garantías de un sufragio
universal pleno para elegir al
gobernador hongkonés nunca se cumplieron
por parte del gobierno central
especialmente desde que llegó al poder
en 2013 el actual líder chino xi jinping
algo que llevó a las primeras protestas
en septiembre de 2014 centenares de
jóvenes rodearon el parlamento hong kong
es para exigir reformas electorales que
garantizarán el sufragio universal una
cuestión que precipitó una dura
respuesta de las autoridades que por
primera vez en la historia usaron gas
contra los ciudadanos y cargaron contra
ellos
estos jóvenes intentaron protegerse como
pudieron con sus paraguas y así es como
nació el movimiento de los paraguas que
paralizó por tres meses hong kong
el movimiento fue desmantelado por las
autoridades pero esto no supondría su
fin de las movilizaciones surgieron
grandes nombres como joshua wong o agnes
show y una corriente pro democrática que
se opondría con firmeza al poder de
beijing con una mejor organización algo
que no pasó desapercibido para xi
jinping que en 2017 lanzó una serie
advertencia
luego
cualquier intento de poner en peligro la
soberanía y la seguridad de china a
desafiar el poder del gobierno central y
la autoridad de la ley básica de la
región administrativa especial de hong
kong shanghai comenzó a utilizar hong
kong para llevar a cabo actividades de
infiltración y sabotaje contra el
continente es un acto que cruza la línea
roja y es absolutamente inadmisible
todos
pero en 2019 todo estalló miles de
personas salieron durante semanas a
protestar contra la gobernadora carril
am y su controversial ley de extradición
las manifestaciones no tuvieron
precedentes y pusieron en jaque a las
autoridades que en varias ocasiones se
vieron desbordadas las voces de los
activistas prodemocráticos comenzaron a
exigir más autodeterminación para hong
kong ante lo que consideraban una
injerencia ilegal del gobierno central
en la política de la antigua colonia
es hora de que urja moza carril a más
retirar la propuesta de ley de
extradición y es su responsabilidad
renunciar y enfrentar como dos millones
de personas ya se unieron a la lucha y
la instaron asumir la responsabilidad
política
un desafío del que tomó nota beijing ya
que comenzó a perseguir ya encarcelar a
líderes opositores con la excusa de ser
terroristas hasta 47 activistas y
legisladores pro democracia fueron
detenidos y están a la espera de juicio
esto unido a la entrada en vigor en 2020
de la ley de seguridad nacional
impulsada por beijing hizo que las
protestas fueran desapareciendo esta
controversial ley castiga con la cadena
perpetua cualquier intento de protesta y
organización contra el poder central una
limitación de libertades que muchos
creen que fue el final de la política de
un país dos sistemas a ella se sumó en
2021 una reforma electoral que sacó del
parlamento cualquier tipo de oposición a
beijing y que hizo que el poder central
tuviera más fuerza en la política hong
kong esa de esta forma llega a hong kong
a la mitad de los 50 años teóricos de un
país dos sistemas en los primeros 25
años una parte importante de las
libertades han sido eliminadas por
beijing lo que hace pensar que hasta
2047 la tendencia continuará en esa
fecha hong kong pasará a ser de forma
integral parte de china con esto
concluimos gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]
i